I'd much rather have a piece of content
go viral on Tick Tock today than have
Good Morning America mention it it's not
even close where people get screwed up
is they think these platforms skew Young
when they don't the amount of
consumption on Tick Tock for example
from 30 to 55 is staggering you know
when every time we in this organization
and every organization that looks like
yours and mine puts up how many
Impressions the article gets nobody
believes the slide that says that we got
three billion impressions
nobody believes that I don't believe
anybody's comms plan here would be the
same if this was their family business
and their livelihood required it and
that's how I do comms marketing I do it
as if my business requires it because
they do because I own all my own
businesses and I'm petrified to lose is
the traditional press release dead you
know what what do you think on that
topic about how we get our news and
stories out there
I don't love thinking about things as
dead because there's probably some
people right now still getting around
the world on a horse
um but I do like to think about things
in our is the value they are against the
time and resources energy and monies we
spend
it's inconceivable to me and I'm seeing
I'm seeing on my screen a lot of the
back of the heads uh I'd be thrilled if
you guys turned around and waved I'd
love to see the faces
um in fact guys let's just do that
everyone turn your chairs face the
camera I can be the voice let's switch
thank you Gary I like this
it's much more real so when I see all
these beautiful faces it's inconceivable
to me
inconceivable that
um that anybody here thinks a press
release is
extraordinarily effective in 2023
right it's a nice to have
but the person that should be doing the
press release
you know maybe it's eight seconds of a
senior person to just quadruple check
but that should be the intern's job
thank you we got a lot of interesting
faces around the room so not asking you
to write our business plan although
maybe I am right what do you think we
should be looking for so opportunities
that you think a Communications Group
such as ours is there something we're
ignoring like if you were building
you've already built it but your comms
team like what might it look like
well I think you know and maybe the team
now that I'm seeing the faces maybe you
can head not or shake your head or
thumbs up like first
let's let's put it this way how much do
does the comms team think that who
they're trying to reach is more B2B than
B to C would you argue it's more B to b
or more B to C
Shaq what do you think so let's go hands
up for b2c in the room
this is mostly a b2c room yeah so the
most the focus of this corporate group
is b2c right so if it's B to C like you
can imagine how the the press release
immediately makes me smile as a
conversation if we're b2c
um if it's B to C all of b2c consumption
is moving by the nanosecond to social
media or connective TV right so you know
when you think of that or podcasting
like everything everything is still the
same truth it's audio written word and
video it's the distribution that's
changed on all of us
everybody here would much rather get a
top all top 10 podcasts to mention
whenever you want the world to know then
top 10 Z100 Morning Zoo drive like the
world's changed
and so we have to change with it I'd
much rather have a piece of content go
viral on Tick Tock today than have Good
Morning America mention it it's not even
close
if I'm trying to get Mass awareness
where people get screwed up is they
think these platforms skew Young when
they don't
the amount of consumption on Tick Tock
for example from 30 to 55 is staggering
actual consumption not potential reach
grps Impressions all these things that
people trade on they're not real you
know when every time we in this
organization and every organization that
looks like yours and mine puts up how
many Impressions the article gets nobody
believes the slide that says that we got
three billion impressions
nobody believes that that's why
everyone's smiling you didn't get to be
a billion Impressions you did some
[ __ ] math around the websites that
mentioned it and decided that was going
to justify it I don't believe anybody's
comms plan here would be the same if
this was their family business and their
livelihood
required it and that's how I do comms
marketing I do it as if my business
requires it because they do because I
own all my own businesses and I'm
petrified to lose and so I don't buy
into yesterday I focus on today the
problem of with businesses of scale is
they think today is the future
the only times there's meetings where
people say things like yeah yeah like
you know tick tock's emerging we'll get
to that when it's you know next year or
the year like what what it is the actual
thing
and so as a comms team more creative
output
against the incredible amounts of
stories that this organization has to
tell
and you have incredible
dining wine
you know emotional stories utility
stories value stories by the way you
have to fragment them I'll give you a
great example
if I'm on this team if I was on this
team I would raise my hand and say can I
do the LinkedIn creative on this team
because I know that I can do unlimited
smart content targeting CFOs to show
them why working with us would save
their company money
and CFOs care about that
and so I would be educated on all the
different
things that we did that could be
thoughtful for B2B travel
and I would make clever video written
word infographic content and I would run
media against CFOs a fortune 5000
companies
and I would give us accounts
love that confidence a lot of Smiles in
this room Gary loving this
um You probably don't remember you see a
lot of folks like me in hotel lobbies
but something I remember from 2018 we
talked you asked me about occupancy and
I think I said at the time the hotel I
was in and that market was currently
running at 82 and I was excited about
the 18 thing that's what you said you've
got a great memory you said well F that
what about the A-Team what are you doing
so right because when you live in a
comms mindset like I do which is day
trading attention
your your calmsing every hour on every
day
this isn't about what are we doing in 37
days which that is as well something on
my mind
this is do we have the capacity at 4 15
pm
to do creative things on social to fill
up the 18 get incredible news PR happy
retention better lifetime value from
current clients trial from new clients
who've been loyal to our competitors
um there's just it's it's an asset
and and if you're smart I'm a
businessman so that there be no
confusion I'm not looking to undermine
our core product I'm not looking to
create expectations of the consumer to
like I don't have to book with them I'll
just wait to 4 15 to get the free room
this is much more clever than that but
yes I remember admittedly as you can
tell excellent so we have lots of Brands
we've got another one yesterday so you
have a favorite obviously we've got the
high-end ones because you are a high
roller so I'm sure you have the Ritz
we've got Saint Regis Marriott Courtyard
we got the whole portfolio you have one
hotel where you're like I love that
place you know what's funny about me
when you um when you bring that up that
I like a lot is I I went to Green Bay
Wisconsin this weekend to watch my um my
favorite Jets play right and we were
talking about you know like because we
were driving back to Chicago and
we were talking about
um hotels because a bunch of my friends
were staying
um at the courtyard and we we loved the
one in Indianapolis
um and so I was talking about how I like
that and like and I was staying at the
same Regis and so it was like they were
making fun of me for being bougie but
what's really really interesting is if
you ask me out of your Brands what which
one first when I travel I actually don't
even know where I stay because most of
my travel
for the majority of my career has been
because I publicly speak a lot and as
you can imagine the organizations are
putting you up often in where the event
is or things that nature so I have like
literally run the gamut however I will
say Aloft
has been like a brand that I actually
like have some weirdly awesome Affinity
towards
um you know
I'm I'm just kind of going off the top
of my head I think that's in your that's
in your I didn't [ __ ] up yeah it's one
of us yeah
um and so uh yeah so I I like that brand
a lot I really do
cool we couldn't let you go today
without talking about the Super Bowl
okay when you started out obviously you
know back in the day did you ever think
I think last year I think you had more
Super Bowl ads than any other agency in
addition to the peanuts campaign on
social investment did you ever really
think that you'd be doing Super Bowl ads
yeah I did I don't know if you remember
back when you discover it we met very
early on
my thesis is attention Arbitrage
you know I would write press releases
tomorrow if I believed people were
consuming them at enough scale against
how much we spend against it hence why I
said again you should still do them I
just think the cost associated with
making them should drive down
dramatically and of course there should
be a few minutes of you know the senior
the Super Bowl I think is the most
underpriced attention in marketing you
get 150 million Americans actually
consuming your spot the issue with Super
Bowl why it doesn't work for a lot of
people is creative agencies use it as a
showcase for their talents not trying to
drive the business for their clients
they use it as a proxy to get new
clients and so you get all these
horseshit ads like the [ __ ] Andy
Warhol Burger King ad of like three
years ago that made no [ __ ] sense
other than the creative agency was
trying to be super [ __ ] clever and
they sold less Burgers because of it
right so yeah that that's a problem but
the media is fantastic and and so
yes I did think we would do Super Why
ads I did know that it would take us a
long time because I knew that
you know still to the state 13 years in
even though we've done the most Super
Bowl spots even though we're the
creative aor of Pepsi and and Budweiser
and you're like all these things I'm
very aware because of me and because
where we grew up people still look at us
as social media which is amazing because
I also think that social media is about
to be viewed like television I think
very quickly I'm sure when I look at the
faces in this room
I know all of you know
because you've been through it in your
careers if I'm getting this right
social media on a yearly by yearly by
yearly basis has taken up more oxygen in
the boardroom I mean 13 years ago it was
an afterthought of an afterthought of an
afterthought now most Fortune 500
companies still blow it they still make
it the matching luggage to the brand
campaign that they do on television
the biggest misstep in marketing that
they come up with a subjective one-line
sentence of what the brand stands for in
a room run TBC and then do digital
matching luggage
but if you know what's happening on
social
you know that it is the infrastructure
to consideration in our universe it's
why politicians get elected it's why
people make consumer decisions and so
I'm starting to sense for the first time
in the last decade and a half that big
brands are starting to understand their
disrespect or lack of skill within
social is starting to become an issue
and I'm excited about it because I
really believe in it I do believe that
the internet is doing to television what
television did to the radio
and I think now that streaming has eaten
up all of Television it's left people
with no choice I mean the thought of
running a television commercial
is asinine to me
the call back to cost it's not that I
don't think people consume a television
commercial of course they get some
but paying the fee for a creative a
award
that just sits around and Ponders ideas
and then you decide you like it and then
you pay a production company to make it
and then you pay that level of media for
potential reach that isn't actually
being consumed
that's a really good way to waste money
in 2023
cool love the point do you have a thing
called see a brand when you're walking
around or streaming whatever you're
doing and thank God I wish venomedia had
those guys as a client I could really
help them I could help him knock the
[ __ ] out of whatever they're doing no
because I'm not I'm not passionate about
the brands I'm passionate about the
casting of the executives that are
actually in genuine belief that we
should be consumer-centric not bonus
boardroom Centric
got it so for me it's not Brands it's
teammates that want to actually do it
right like like I'm very empathetic like
every human that I'm looking at right
now needs to care about their family
that's exactly right and so if the
corporate structure is we are mmm or MMA
or the way we reward or what you need to
accomplish are these rules you must
follow those rules you're not in the
business of getting fired
I'm looking for organizations that are
changing the rules
right that that are trying to make them
about business results based on
marketing
and to me that is exciting because
otherwise if you're not based on if
you're not trying to get business
results based on marketing
you either have a bad business or you
become vulnerable to some of the things
that I'm sure some of the brands in this
building are vulnerable to which is
you're paying toll booths to get you
customers
Google
middleware companies that give you
referrals that you pay huge fees to
because you're not marketing well enough
and the reason we don't Market well
enough is we don't win on consideration
enough Shaq we don't win on
consideration because we don't win on
relevance look at the faces here
for me to get you to buy this or to book
a hotel room or to buy this
can you imagine trying to make one piece
of video get everyone in this room to
give a [ __ ] about that that's insane
this is about context and relevance
which requires a level of creative
output and a media strategy that is
wildly different than what most
companies do and that's the battleground
of comms now
oh I love that I'm going to switch gear
just got a quick thumb one then I've got
a another one about one of your other
books um
you talk a lot about the Jets so you and
your brother apparently haven't missed a
game one of my colleagues in the room
earlier asked me said you know what if
Mr Marriott asked Gary to come to a
meeting but it was joined at Jets game
never you think he'd come you wouldn't
come for Mr Marriott not only for Mr
Marriott Miss Mary it's not even in the
[ __ ] ball game I've missed weddings
funerals birthdays I do not miss jet
games I am think about the most
religious person you've ever known
whatever their religion is and whatever
they need to do Friday Shabbat Sunday
church
whatever that is that person is not even
in the universe to my religion of the
Jets I have not missed watching a play
of a New York Jets game since 1982. I've
watched them all
so how are you looking for that
acquisition purchase deal how long is it
going to take I've been waiting a while
my friend my great professional ambition
is
Chase to try to buy them
if I can just get it done before I die
I'd be very happy
hey very cool
um
you talk a lot about diff about about
it's more about you know never never
give up tenacity it doesn't matter how
old you are but I think you talk about
some of the Gen Z folks need to have a
little bit more patience yes you also
talk about you know people like myself
into their 40s now although I think when
I saw the article you wrote it said in
their 70s you'd encourage folks to be
start in businesses I think you said
just because you're 75 you still got 15
good years in you go start a business so
I don't want any of the uh it was yes it
was less about start a business it's
more like when I look at this room I'm
like man
do they really realize how young they
are because I don't think they do
because it's not the way the propaganda
of age has been sold to us over the last
hundred years I don't believe this room
including you Shaq because you're
getting up there brother I don't believe
that you know anybody in this room
really has a good enough grasp of how
much time they actually have I think
that you know when I look
everybody knock on wood obviously
horrific things happen or tragic things
happen but knock on wood everybody I'm
looking at 40. 40 more years that's for
me and you Shack like there's some
youngsters like 50
50 60. like that is a lot of time and so
you know I don't think people fight for
joy and happiness enough
they're they're based on fear they're
based on
the financial obligations the
theoretical emotional obligations
they've made them for themselves for
their spouses and their children
and you know I really do believe being
the best version of yourself
requires a level of strategic
selfishness which is grounded in if I'm
really happy I can make everybody I love
happier
and if I'm really happy
you know everything clicks and you know
it's funny because I'm such an
entrepreneur but my relationship with
money is very weird you know you know
like I really
I don't like what it does to people I
think it confuses people I don't think
people have a good relationship with
money or time and you know I'm very
fortunate the thing I love you know I
was a six-year-old Who Sold lemonade and
shoveled driveways like I love it I love
the game of business but for a lot of
people they don't love what they do but
it they're doing it because it's it's
paying for their lifestyle
and you know I I you know I'm very
fortunate that I have so many people
consuming my content that I want to use
that for good and I like talking about
real things and I think one of the most
real things on earth is
people are dramatically younger than
they think they have so much time to
expand their interests their
capabilities
the professional ambitions
you know I'm passionate about it I want
to talk about it I think the world has
gotten very good at selling fear and
Hate
and I want to sell
practical optimism I'm not delusional
I'm a very practical operator this is
not like the secret like sit at home and
pray that you'll be a professional skier
that [ __ ] doesn't work but what does
work is hey if you love skiing believe
it or not
try to make some skiing videos on Tick
Tock and see what the world does with it
you'll never believe what can happen and
I know it to be true because at this
point 15 years into this journey
my hundreds of thousands of emails from
people that have taken one piece of
content done it and something good has
happened whether it's as simple as hey
Gary we really got into the garage sale
stuff that you were telling us our
family likes it we have a lot of fun on
Saturdays but we made eight thousand
dollars on the side and now we can
afford this Disney trip thank you
all the way to
I thought it was crazy but I was really
down in the dumps and I was an executive
making 300K a year and I started making
YouTube videos and tick tocks around
Star Trek because you told me to make it
around the thing I love the most and I'm
a Trekkie and oh my God you know I now
between affiliate merch sales and
sponsorship make 200 000 a year and I
just quit my job that I hated and I can
you know not making as much yet but I'm
87 000 times happier have more time to
be with my kids and by next year I bet
you I make 300 000 a year that's
profound that is a profound profound
life change and so yes I push it I push
it on my own employees
I want people to be happier because the
net of that is a good thing
very cool we got a couple of folks in
the room most have been with this
company a little while but some of the
new guys or Young Folks you know
starting out on their careers what
advice might you give to them
die on your own sword
and let me explain what I mean by that
there's a lot of youngsters in here who
fundamentally and by the way a lot of OG
gangsters in here that do not believe in
what you're doing with your time and
money to create the outcome you want but
they keep their mouth shuts in the
meetings because they are being
protective of their professional careers
and I understand that
you're not going to be able to
communicate your points of view the way
I am because I own my own business I
don't have a board I'm not a publicly
traded company so when I lose stuff or
bad things happen I look in the mirror
and say don't do that again for you
there's more ramifications I respect
that however
that doesn't mean that you are not able
to very respectfully to your leaders and
managers very cordially very charmingly
able to communicate your
disagreement or different point of view
on what you should be doing from a com
standpoint
the reason I say die in your own sword
is the following I believe the next
decade will be the most significant
decade of the last two decades which one
of the two most significant Decades of
comms changing because of Technology
it really stinks
to lose your job or not progress in your
career because you weren't articulating
things you believed in that ended up
becoming true and you got no credit for
it because you played defense and the
culture of the company made you not say
it not your own belief system so you
missed out on the opportunity
because of that that is devastating
so please find a way to cordially
communicate your personal opinions
you're allowed to be wrong I'm wrong
people are wrong but you've got to share
your actual thoughts head nodding in a
corporate environment for the sake of
head nodding is always a bad strategy
thank you I got a couple of quick fies
and then we'll wrap this thing up so
um is there a brain a brand obviously
not not don't include us but is that one
brand out there you really admire I'm
sure it's one of your clients it's you
know it's not uh meaning I'm very happy
with what our clients do I actually
spend very little time looking at what
other clients do because the industry of
marketing is completely based on its own
self everything is about headlines and
awards and [ __ ] reporting so the
creative industry is super not
interesting to me right it's so I care
about consumer the reason I have one to
call out is it's the only client in the
last three years that I after a couple
of meetings I told them not to hire us
because they didn't meet us
which was
extremely upsetting to my new business
team they're still mad about it
um and that was Chipotle I think
Chipotle is a brand that understands
that Marketing in 2023 requires doing
things of the moment
and as all of you know we're slow in
companies like this because we have too
much process our partners are slow we're
slow and speed is the killer so I have a
lot of respect for how they Market they
understand that context and timing is
everything and they do very very well in
building a small internal team and
having a framework that isn't based on
Creative aor or overpaying for [ __ ]
and I respect it
okay I'm gonna go back to my TV days so
when I finally leave Marriott in about
26 years I'm going to start my own TV
company and I'm going to produce Gary
venicek the movie who do you think I
should cast to play you come on I would
say it you know and hopefully at that
point you'll have like three different
actors you know to play out the whole
thing and so whomever are the most
attractive three men at the time
that kind of somewhat look like me but
are just much better looking versions
would feel right Shaq would feel
absolutely right everything I do
is based on consumer reaction
so the reason I need faces is when I say
something I need to get a sense of did
it land
faces are the great I mean it's
unbelievable why I think I have a big
public speaking career it's because I
focus on the front row and I completely
bounce off of them the entire time and
those seven people completely dictate
how good or not good my keynote's gonna
be and so like even when I go to some
sort of conferences that all of you know
like the whole room's too dark and you
can't see I actually ask for them to put
up the light I would argue
that this is what I want to say in my
final minute
try to do more stuff for actual
consumers
it's really in our subconscious it's in
my own agency all 2000 people globally I
can see it every day a lot of it's
within the B2B or the way it's been done
give all your thoughts to responding to
the actual consumer
these Brands Shack when I look at them
and now I just I just clicked on the
website so there's a lot of Brands right
when I look at that I genuinely believe
that the holding Co should be putting
out somewhere in the ballpark of 200 to
500 pieces of creative a day across
social
think about that number
like and I'm and I'm not hyperbolizing
here I genuinely believe that that Ritz
Carlton and the W and JW Marriott like
and I think about how Global you are on
a bad day I'm even trying to it's funny
I just felt myself lowballing the number
because I didn't want people to think I
was hyperbolizing and get laughed out of
the room on a bad day this organization
should be putting out 200 to 500
individual different pieces of creative
globally across LinkedIn Tick Tock
Facebook reels Instagram Twitter a day
we all know that we're not even in the
realm of that and like every other time
in the last 15 years I will be
historically correct about this
statement over the next five years So
the faster you can figure out how to
drive down the cost of creative
internally and with your partners you
will become a calm Supernova if you can
do that and I know that's hard but it's
worth the debate for these leaders and
yourself
we love that thank you so much I'm going
to come and see you in New York soon
cheers me thank you thank you appreciate
it buddy cheers
foreign
[Music]